تتراقَصُ الأغصانْ
تتمايلُ الزهورْ
إن غرَّدتْ أطيارْ
نحنُ نحنُ الطيورْ
مذكور في القران *** يضرب بي الأمثال
أنا الهدهد الجميل ***  دائم الترحال
أنا الهدهد الجميل ***   دائم الترحال
نحن نحن الطيور
أنا اللقلق أنا *** متعدد الأسماء
منقاري طويل*** ألتقط به الغذاء
نحن نحن الطيور
أعيش في الحقول *** أتغذى على البذور
ريشي فيه خطوط *** أنا طائر السمان
نحن نحن الطيور
تتراقَصُ الأغصانْ
تتمايلُ الزهورْ
إن غرَّدتْ أطيارْ
نحنُ نحنُ الطيورْ
أنا الدُّوري أنا   ***  متباين الألوان
تشو تشو تشو تشو  ***  ما أجمل عيناي
نحن نحن الطيور
خطوطيَ سوداء  ***  معروفة بالغناء
وحجمي صغير  ***  أنا القُبَّرة السمراء
نحن نحن الطيور
أنا البلبل أنا ***  منفرد بالجمال
أبيض الخدين  *** طليق اللسان
نحن نحن الطيور
تتراقَصُ الأغصانْ
تتمايلُ الزهورْ
إن غرَّدتْ أطيارْ نحنُ نحنُ الطيورْ
نحن نحن الطيور